go
[Music]
i think by virtue of
the way we've defined the physical
consciousness is not physical by
definition and worse yet it cannot even
be reduced to the physical because of
that definition you see we define the
physical
as
basically that which has no phenomenal
qualities that which is exhaustively
described in terms of a list of abstract
quantities such as
mass charge momentum spin geometric
relationships frequency amplitude and so
on and so forth
and of course there is nothing about
these abstract quantities in terms of
which we could deduce
the quality of seeing a red apple or
tasting the apple or the quality of
filling a bellyache or falling in love
so by definition we've turned these two
domains into incommensurable domains one
is a given experience the qualities of
our inner life and the other is a
conceptual creation
the physical world
i think the way this divide came about
was that quantities are very handy
for uh describing the relative
differences of the qualities of
experience for instance
if i see red that's different from
seeing blue and there is a very handy
way to describe this difference in terms
of a frequency delta which is a number
but then we've taken this description
this handy description of relative
differences between qualities
and we said well this is actually
an existent it exists in and of itself
and we called it matter and energy or
the physical world out there we gave it
an ontological reality that it didn't
have in the beginning it was a mere
description of something else
and worse yet we not only edified it as
an independent ontological reality
we now try to reduce the qualities which
were which is where we started to that
conceptual creation of consciousness
which exists in consciousness and that
of course cannot work
it is obvious that there is a world out
there independent of my mind your mind
anybody's mind there is a world up there
that has an autonomous independent
existence it exists in and of itself so
it's outside our individual personal
minds but then we very discreetly
put an extra unexamined step on this
statement we said not only is this world
outside
anybody's individual mind
it is outside mind as an ontological
category it is something else
what's something else well those numbers
that were we used in a very handy way to
describe the relative differences of
experience
that's where it goes wrong
i think the objective world up there
exists but it is constituted by
transpersonal mental state which
presents to us in the form in the form
we call physicality just as my
phenomenal inner life presents itself to
you in the form of the matter that
constitutes my body
[Music]
you